moving on to the Southwest Medical
hospice scared the sponsors of this
segment provide the Right Care at the
right time and with the right companion
here's more
my name is Cynthia lau and I have been
living in Henderson for about 25 years
I'm an occupational therapist by
training and I teach at Toro University
in Henderson in the graduate program
preparing a future occupational
therapist
I started to do
hospice
visits with Southwest last year and this
is my dog Archie he's a certified
therapy dog and sometimes he goes with
me to add cheer cheer and joy to the
clients in hospice I have three adult
children who are all at college right
now when they were growing up we instill
in them a very strong sense of community
service it was really important that we
all gave back as a family when they were
all gone this past year I just wanted a
volunteer experience that was more
perhaps impactful and personal and
Southwest Medical actually really fit
the bill in the hospice program it
allows me to build really personal
relationships with the clients and I
really enjoy that
Archie is a Australian labradoodle and
by his breed he just loves people he
plays Fetch with some of the
clients in hospice they get a big kick
out of that and it gives them an
opportunity to talk about their own pets
throughout their lives and and they've
had many pets throughout their lives so
that that makes a really fun
conversation recently a caregiver
of a family told me
the paid shop they come they're they're
respectful they're kind they do the
necessary tasks however the volunteers
come to talk to her family member just
for the sole reason of bringing joy and
comfort and that was really a Priceless
feedback that I received to not
underestimate my role as a volunteer we
all need help during life Transitions
and this is a major life transition and
volunteers provide a invaluable
service to the community it's really
meaningful it's personal I have a
clinical Healthcare background however I
feel that any adult person of any
background could be successful as a
volunteer because Southwest Medical
provides the level of support and
supervision necessary for that one thing
I really learned from the hospice
volunteers is a very different
perspective of living
and that's been really
really rewarding for me I feel very
honored to listen to their life stories
and it I just hope that
with me being there I add some comfort
and dignity to their day
and that is my objective
thank you to Southwest Medical for
sponsoring this segment for more
information you can call
702-671-1111 or visit the webpage on
your screen we'll be right back
[Music]